on va démarrer très fort ce soir je vous
dis tout de suite déjà je voudrais vous
montrer une image c'est quelque chose
qui est fait aux apo très régulièrement
c'est une petite caméra cachée regardez
ce qu'il faut soc 9 nov m'a dit d'où
cette magie autostart sonauto qui
alors
c'est ce qui fait au japon mais y'en a
qui va venir nous rejoindre autour de la
table dans un instant c'est bertrand
chamerois bars à chats maurage suis pas
si vous le connaissez bertrand charleroi
il est tous les soirs dans l'émission
c'est le beau gosse de l'émission il
fait un travail magnifique et je lui dis
on va faire croire que tu es en duplex
au japon donc il est dans une loge il ne
sait pas ce qui va lui arriver dès ce
début
maintenant vous êtes donc en duplex du
japon en bertrand tout à fait connu de
chaud avoue cyril ça va super on est au
japon il fait bon vivre japon vous savez
sert il vous allez devenir nous
rejoindre dans un resto de ce que vous
vous déplacez très vite
oui bien sûr ça mais on est en 2015 tout
se passe en une seconde
alors ça va vous n'êtes pas trop pendue
à claque un peu claqué mais ça va ah oui
vous êtes bien claquer la whey ça je
suis à ckac et la wii balance je pense
que c'est le moment que vous soyez
encore un peu plus qu'à quai
robert tran ba c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon c'est bon c'est bon ça va bien tout
va bien tout va très bien et c'est bien
à l'aise ben oui je suis bien à l'aise
ouais ouais voilà malaisie n'a assez bon
ça va aller merci ballon c'est la vôtre
naya qu'est ce qui va se passer ça c'est
bon bah c'est bon voilà encore tout va
bien mais voilà bond à merci et bien je
vous en prie maine-et-loire sont pas
tout à fait mais bien sûr j'y vais bien
sûr
dans cette émission que vous serez très
bien je sens très très bien que la sent
très bien cette émission aller